but we begin with breaking news an
earthquake on a terrifying scale
officials say it's a magnitude 7.8 Quake
centered near the border between turkey
and Syria and there have been multiple
strong aftershocks more than 1300 people
are dead and that number is expected to
rise as rescue workers dig through the
rubble it's one of the strongest
earthquakes ever to hit this area and
there's reports that it was felt up to A
Thousand Miles Away MTS tire has the
very latest
the scale of the devastation is hard to
Fathom as rescue workers desperately
search for survivors in the biting cold
some people still trapped under the
rubble are posting videos of themselves
on social media begging for help
[Music]
the early morning 7.8 magnitude
earthquake struck as most people slept
since then there have been dozens of
aftershocks the most recent and
strongest measuring 7.5 so little has
been spared including the city of
gaziantep's historic Castle which has
stood for over 2 000 years parts of it
now in Ruins just over the border and
the last rebel-controlled corner of
Syria which is packed with some 4
million people displaced from the
country's long and brutal Civil War even
more misery small survivors are pulled
from the rubble
and as hospitals overflow with the
injured and the dead the opposition
Syrian Civil Defense known as the white
helmets are no stranger to rescuing
people from large-scale destruction but
even they have never witnessed anything
like this North we're seeing now it's
disaster area we need help
from everyone to to to to save our
people turkey sits on one of the world's
most active fault lines it is frequently
shaken by earthquakes back in 1999
around 18 000 were killed when a
powerful Quake struck the northwest of
the country now for those of us who have
reported extensively on the Syrian war
and from Eastern Turkey I can tell you
there are a few places on Earth that are
home to as many millions of people
already traumatized and displaced by War
than there and now this massive disaster
making matters even worse the earthquake
comes as the Middle East is experiencing
a bitterly cold snow storm that is
expected to last all week David
the context matters thank you MTS